[Musique]
la paroisse notre dame d'afrique accueil
de la visitera deux évêques congolais
président de la messe et réclame des
prières pour leur pays en crise
lorsqu'elle a pété du pouvoir l'appétit
de l'avoir prend le dessus
monseigneur à bongo vient d'être nommé
évêque de kinshasa la capitale de la
république démocratique du congo
il est au coeur du combat de l'église
catholique là bas qui réclament le
départ du président joseph kabila au
pouvoir depuis 2000
parfois ces gens ont dix ans sur la main
ils ont peur une fois le pouvoir perdu
ils auront à rendre compte
et là ça fait peur ils n'osent pas
lâcher c'est que le pays est en
déliquescence
on dirait même que le combo est un bon
état le peuple congolais aujourd'hui se
sent complètement abandonné
les évêques avaient réussi à régler la
dernière crise en 2016
en forçant la présidence et l'opposition
a signé une entente prévoyant la tenue
d'élections sans joseph kabila
mais le président à renier son
engagement l'église a donc abandonné son
rôle de médiateur
la place de l'église ce n'est pas d'être
neutre au milieu d'un puissant qui
massacrent un p tit mais le rôle de
l'église c'est d'être à côté du p tit
c'est lui qui souffle quand le peuple et
c'est de s'exprimer
on lui répond par des balles et des
balles réelles
tout en repoussant les élections l'an
dernier joseph kabila a lancé une
offensive contre ses opposants tortures
et disparitions sont devenus la norme en
les exécutions sommaires ont grimpé
selon l'onu 250 % devant cette violence
l'église a décidé de plonger dans la
mêlée
les évêques organise des messes anti
kabila et des marches populaires les
policiers n'hésitent pas à siéger les
églises pour disperser les foules
la lutte continue nous devons continuer
mais pacifiquement avec nos chapelles et
à partir de ce moment à montréal les
congolais se mobilisent aussi ils
souhaitent que les pays qui envoient des
millions de dollars en rdc comme le
canada intervienne pour faire cesser les
massacres à cette manifestation
pacifique
il ya des tués riz il ya deux morts le
peuple a fait sa part
là également il faut que la communauté
internationale nous accompagne ça nous
empêche de dormir puisque on sait
exactement comment ça se passe mais peut
avoir dovi d'électricité des patrons
sécurité voir des militaires partout
c'est savoir violée tuée à bout de champ
c'est vraiment terrible pour ces femmes
nous profitons tous sans savoir de la
guerre au congo
car il permet d'exploiter arabes et des
minerais comme coltan utilisé dans les
téléphones cellulaires le contribuable
québécois est capable d'influencer les
décideurs pour comprendre que s'il ya du
saut dans nos cellulaires il ya du saut
dans nos voitures électriques et il est
temps que la maman qu'on les mamans
québécoise qui porte dans son sein les
enfants comprennent que quelque part il
ya des enfants qui meurent au congo un
enfant peut mourir en travaillant dans
les mines ou comme enfants soldats
et maintenant en allant à la messe comme
avatar est à mon sens
les prières des congolais ne suffisent
pas le président joseph kabila promet
maintenant des élections pour décembre
mais il refuse de s'engager à quitter le
pouvoir ce qui ne fait qu'attiser la
colère
l'unique porte de sortie pacifique
c'est qu'on lui laisse l'occasion
d'aller aux urnes et de s'exprimer
mais si on empêche de le faire nous
craignons que ça peut fonctionner à ce
moment là comme une bombe par étapes
[Musique]
où